[Music]
quantum mechanics and thermodynamics are
separated by decades of experience and
knowledge about our universe and yet
they are intimately related in this
fascinating new book called quantum
steampunk by dr nicole younger halpert
we go on a journey through the deepest
annals of thermodynamics to the most
cutting edge knowledge that we have
about quantum mechanics she's a delight
to talk to we talked about maxwell's
demon ooh so scary we talked about the
irreducible quantities and qualities of
quantum mechanics and thermodynamics and
how they can be melded together of
course i ask her my thrilling three
patented questions at the very end
you'll want to stay tuned for that
and if you take nothing else away from
this
you will get a delightful journey to the
victorian age sort of a throwback to
burning man in a thermodynamic sense of
course so come along on this journey
into the impossible with dr nicole
younger helper let's go
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
and ladies and gentlemen
children of all ages step right up for a
steampunk adventure
today's episode
is with the incomparable
nicole younger halpern who was referred
to me by a mutual friend professor
stefan alexander my oldest best friend
from brown university
and he just sent me a cryptic email
intro to today's guest
and he said you have to meet her and you
have to have her on your show and
whatever he says i do except for try
some jamaican jerk chicken recipe or
trinidadian
tri-tip that once caught my mouth on
fire at a trinidadian restaurant in
boston we're not going to talk about
that we're going to talk about even
farther back in the past to the
victorian steampunk era with today's
wonderful guest dr nicole younger
halpern who is a uh a joint a fellow of
the qics
the joint center for quantum information
and computer science
at the university of maryland and uh and
that is where i believe you're joining
us from right nicole
i'm in maryland how are you
doing well it's great to be here
it's good to have you here i love this
book it's published by john's
johns hopkins i always forget is it john
hopkins at johns hopkins but it's johns
hopkins university press a lovely
imprint we've had on several guest uh
authors from there and uh so nicole uh i
always love to
start off by asking my authors who grace
me with their presence
the question you're never ever supposed
to do and ask and that is to judge a
book by its cover but in this case this
is your first book if i am not mistaken
and
uh and it's an unusual book in a
delightful way but what other piece of
quantum information or classical
information do we have to go on besides
the title and the cover uh so i want to
ask you how did you come up with the
title and the cover in what we call
judging books by their covers
[Music]
i work as a researcher at the
intersection of three fields
quantum physics information science
and thermodynamics i see this
intersection of fields as sharing the
spirit of steampunk steampunk is
sometimes seen as a genre of science
fiction it's a genre of literature art
and film it features victorian settings
some of the earliest factories
that are belching smoke into the smoggy
london air
and sherlock holmes and men in top hats
and women in petticoats
there are these settings together with
futuristic technologies like time
machines rigibles and automata so
steampunk has this wonderful sense of
adventure and nostalgia that comes from
reaching back into the past and reaching
into the future
my work involves as i mentioned
thermodynamics which is the science of
energy the different forms that energy
can have and the way that energy can
transform amongst those forms
thermodynamics was developed during the
industrial revolution which was being
powered by some of the first steam
engines and people wanted to understand
how efficiently engines could pump water
out of mines and power factories
so
thermodynamics developed during the
victorian era to describe
big classical systems like steam engines
but today we have great control over
technologies that are much much
different that are small scale and
quantum that could consist of just a few
atoms or molecules or even photons
particles of light
in the context of
quantum information science we can use
strange quantum phenomena like
superpositions and entanglement and
quantum uncertainty to process
information in ways impossible for just
classical systems for instance quantum
computers will be able to solve certain
problems much much more quickly than any
computer that we have today
so quantum computers and other quantum
technologies are
partially futuristic because we don't
have a large scale quantum computer yet
but they're also cutting edge science
so we need to adapt
the thermodynamics of the 1800s to be
able to describe these new small and
quantum settings and so this
intersection of thermodynamics and
quantum information science i see is
sharing the character of steampunk
because it reaches back to the 1800s and
also ahead to the future so that's where
the term
[Music]
and the subtitle is uh the physics of
yesterday's tomorrow which kind of
sounds like a janice joplin song but um
uh and walk us through the cover the
cover has this unusual you know goggles
that maybe i've seen in my burning man
days which are far behind me uh but
nevertheless uh what is that
these optics on the front what does this
represent
yes i wish i could take credit for the
cover because i love it but
unfortunately i can't take any crucially
i can't take any credit
my acquisitions editor at johns hopkins
university press tiffany was
working with an artistic team to create
the cover and those goggles come from
how quantum steampunk costumes tend to
feature goggles fans of steampunk dress
up in costumes with
top hats and corsets and goggles and all
sorts of other victorian slash
futuristic looking paraphernalia so
that's where the goggles come from and
one of the goggles has a cartoon of an
atom on it to invoke the quantum nature
of this combination yeah it does kind of
have this beautiful whimsical um
uh
approach to it which i found really
delightful and it was evocative to me in
my humble opinion of a book by a past
guest you may have heard of him his name
is sir roger penrose and he wrote a
wonderful book that actually was the
first popular science book i ever read
not that i understood it when i was
about 16 years old in high school
and he inspired me and it was called the
emperor's new mind and it's about minds
and machines and artificial intelligence
but it's also this whimsically you know
illustrated uh work and it has
connections to some of the topics you
talk about and i want to start with
something i find uh you know delightful
and i actually used it in my
conversation which aired with professor
sarah walker yesterday uh we're
recording today is st patrick's day uh
march 17 2022 but i aired an episode
with sarah walker yesterday on the 16th
and in it i quoted you uh so you'll have
to watch that episode uh for a shout out
but i talk about how uh in in your book
you talk about entropy and entropy is
this magical mysterious thing and you
quote maybe it's von neumann or some
other you know hungarian or so forth
that makes a lot of appearances in this
book but
quote like when you don't know what to
call something call it entropy
and i wonder what is intro if i wake you
up an intelligent alien or me wakes you
up and you know gives you a 3 a.m phone
call that people in washington talk
about all the time
how do you answer that what what the
heck is entropy what does it mean to you
at a core visceral level
yes
that's a great quote
so entropy comes to us
in one sense from
basically thermodynamics or statistical
mechanics which is very closely related
to thermodynamics so it showed up there
during
the
development of thermodynamics and then
it showed up in information theory which
was developed by claude shannon in the
20th century and claude shannon explains
why he used the phrase or the the name
entropy for this quantity that he had
put together for some mathematical
reasons to explain or to quantify the
efficiencies of some information
processing tasks
he says that he did talk to john von
neumann this amazing hungarian-american
mathematical physicist
and von neumann told me uh told him you
should call it entropy for two reasons
in the first place this function that
you've come up with an information
theory it's already been used in
statistical mechanics under that name
and in the second place
nobody really knows what entropy is so
in a debate you'll always have the
advantage
and so that's why i do information
theory so i have a question that's
always kind of plagued me which is the
notion of whether or not
we really have a good understanding of
what constitutes
say physics or thermodynamics uh and and
in essence my question is you know where
does physics end and where does
chemistry begin i mean i think of
thermodynamics outside of the quantum
thermodynamics you describe here it's
almost like chemicals and molecules and
and not necessarily um divorced from
chemistry but i guess my my crisp
question yeah where is there a hard
dividing line a bright line between
chemistry and physics in terms of you
know micro and macroscopic
uh you know perspectives
one thing that really appeals to me
about thermodynamics is that it is so
general and it's a theory that applies
and applies to and governs many other
theories so
cosmology as you're aware obeys
thermodynamics and biophysics and
condensed matter anatomic molecular and
optical physics so
all different scales across the universe
obey this sort of overarching theory so
thermodynamics does show up in physics
and in chemistry and in engineering
when i was in
biology class in ninth grade and
learning about
the
[Music]
phylums and genuses and species and so
on my teacher said there are some people
who are lumpers and some people who are
splitters
which one you are determines to what
extent you think that different
organisms should go into the same
category or into different categories
although i'm very fond of organizing
things so there's part of me that's
naturally a splitter i'm very much a
lumper in that i love interdisciplinary
studies and i think that
um what i'm doing is just
theoretical physics and i can do
theoretical physics while
collaborating with a chemist who thinks
of himself actually as a physical
chemist in some cases
i think that
maybe it's not so important at least to
me personally and in my work it's
not necessary to draw these dividing
lines because i think it's can be so
valuable to reach across discipline
disciplinary boundaries and instead
one of the most fascinating aspects of
both this book and thermodynamics in
general is the concept of these demons
and there's a few different demons who
make their appearances here and they're
not malevolent uh demons don't worry but
um but talk about this concept of
maxwell's demon and i've heard claims
you know and it seems like there are
often times sabina hossenfeld our past
guest on the show jokes that you know
every time uh the black hole information
loss problem is solved she she tweets
out black hole information loss solved
again and she's been doing this for like
10 years now but i often hear this about
you know things like maxwell's demons
and the second law of thermodynamics can
you explain what is maxwell's demon
and uh and then recent claims you know
uh that that have been
uh postulated that that you could
actually evade the second law of
thermodynamics in a sense so that'll
require you to define the second law of
thermodynamics um uh so first what is
maxwell's demon why is it why does it
feature so heavily as not a villain in
this book but but sort of a thematic
you know
the resonance in this book
the second law of thermodynamics has
many different faces there are many
different ways that you can state it one
way to state it is if you have any
closed isolated system like a gas in a
box
then it's entropy which is some
well i can i guess i can get to in a
moment what i think of entropy as its
entropy either grows or stays constant
but does not decrease
and this growing of entropy is
how we might think of the arrow of time
now i think of entropy as
a measure of how many different
configurations a system can be in so if
you have a gas in a box then this
molecule can be over here or over here
over here or over here
and it can have many different momentum
and the more ways you can
arrange the particles in the box and the
more different momenta you can give the
particles the larger the entropy the
system has so if the particles are all
clumped together in one corner of the
box to begin with then if they're just
limited to that one corner then there
aren't so very many ways you can
rearrange them
but if you start with them all clumped
together in a corner and then you wait
they will spread out all across the box
and there will be many many many more
configurations available to them
so the entropy of this gas in a box
increases as time goes on
so this
this rule
was developed a long time ago and some
people are
thought that they could get around it
and even today i think it's fun to come
up with thought experiments to see how
to what extent we might try to break the
second law of thermodynamics
to my knowledge there is no breaking of
the second law of thermodynamics one
could
bend around the second law of
thermodynamics maybe by
setting up scenario that doesn't quite
obey the assumptions behind the second
law of thermodynamics but as far as i
know it's still going strong and one of
the tests that a number of us think it
has stood up to is the maxwell demon
paradox
so james clark maxwell was a british
scientist who was also famous for coming
up with a unified theory of electricity
and magnetism
he said okay suppose that we have this
gas in a box whose entropy properties
are supposedly so simple to understand
and suppose that there's a partition in
the middle of the box and there's a
little doorway in the middle of the
partition furthermore there's a
finite being as he called it
later colleagues of his called it a
demon who can open the door and let
particles through or close the door and
prevent particles from going through
suppose that this game this demon
watches the particles
and
finds that some of the particles move
toward the door with a high speed
anytime
that a particle moves with high speed
from the right of the box then the demon
lets it through and any time a particle
uh approaches the door with a low speed
then the demon lets it through into the
right hand side
uh particles if if you have a guess then
its particles are moving at certain
speeds and
the
higher the speeds of the gas particles
the hotter the gas is
so eventually
all of the
slow-moving particles are going to be in
the right-hand side of the box so the
right-hand side of the box is going to
have a cold gas and the left-hand side
of the box is going to have a hot gas so
the demon will
just use his measurements and his
control over the door in order to create
a temperature difference
if you have two different gases at two
different temperatures and you have an
engine then you can
let heat flow from hot to cold through
the engine and you can
use the temperature difference to
perform work like powering a car or a
factory or pushing a rock up a hill or
charging a battery
and after you have performed this
process with the engine then
the gases will have mixed again and
you'll have just
one fairly uniform gas spread out across
the box
so
and the demon could do this many many
many times
and
one can argue that the demon does not
himself increase or experience an
increase in entropy and also
ideally in at least theoretical physics
in principle as we say
the engine does not need to experience
an increase in entropy so you could
power as many cars as you like
while
again and again just returning the gas
to the same initial state so it seems
like you can accomplish a whole lot get
a whole lot of work out of this gas
without really changing its state and
that just seems wrong and in fact it
violates the second law of
thermodynamics so maxwell said ha what
do you make of that
and
there has been a lot of debate about
maxwell's demon
there is
not complete agreement throughout the
physical the physics world but
quite a lot of agreement in the physics
world
that maxwell's demon paradox has been
resolved by
a few steps there was another great
hungarian-american physicist called
silard who made the first step or one of
the first steps and then rolf landauer
who was an information scientist at ibm
and these steps were put together with a
bit more by charlie bennett who is an
information scientist at ibm
and he says
we're actually missing something
important about the demon
so when the demon measures particles
then he records in some memory
each particle's speed
and if we really want to argue
that
the
gas ends up in the same state as it was
after the engine is used
then
really the whole system has to end up in
the same state the demon as well and so
the demon has to erase his memory now it
had been shown by landauer that erasing
information costs thermodynamic work so
the demon can extract work from the
temperature difference but he'll have to
use that work in order to erase his
memory and so on balance he'll get
no
network out of the gas in a box and so
the second law is a number of yes if you
mentioned louder and we'll get to that
there's another
um
kind of a topic that your response kind
of elicited me and that had to do with
these uh quantum you know teapots that
you talk about quite frequently in the
book um and this is uh not unrelated i
think to to the same sorts of of um
of issues of maxwell's demons in that
you have this uh you have this
incredible you know kind of minimal
minimalistic in a good sense way of
distilling down these very complicated
topics in a way that non-experts and i'm
not an expert when it comes to quantum
thermodynamics i don't know how many
experts there are it's only been around
for a few years
uh but in its in its current form but
can you talk about these sillard you
know engines and things like that how do
they relate to maxwell's demons are they
just you know basically another way of
of restating this age-old problem or do
they fundamentally revolutionize our
understanding of these thermodynamic
connections to information because as i
recall from your wonderful description
it's it's tangentially related but it's
really about information these uh these
types of engines so can you explain what
those are
sure
so maxwell's demon paradox involves this
simple model of
gas in a box
and the
what charlie bennett pointed out was the
close connection between
the thermodynamic manipulation of the
gas to get work
and
information processing namely erasure of
the demon's memory
an important couple of steps on the way
to
bennett's resolution of the paradox came
from
sealerd and landauer and they showed
through some similar but slightly
different very simple thought
experiments how
thermodynamic
energy and information are very closely
bound up so there are two types of
energy that can be transferred in
between objects heat and work
the heat is
the energy of random motion of particles
jiggling around it's
random it's uncoordinated it's not being
directly harnessed to do something
useful
work is useful energy it is organized in
a sense so you can directly use it to
again push a rock up a hill or power a
factory
sailor showed that if you have
information
and this useless heat you can use the
information to turn useless heat into
useful work so he imagines also a gas in
a box because that is one of the
favorite settings for thought
experiments of physicists
but imagine that our the gas in the box
is so very simple that it just consists
of one particle and suppose that you
have one bit of information about the
particle so a bit the bit is the basic
unit of information
it's a
the information that you have if you or
that you learn if you learn the answer
to a yes or no question
so suppose that you know that the
particle is in the left hand side of the
box rather than the right hand side of
the box
so you know left rather than right so
you know one of two possible options
that's why you have a bit
then you can slide a partition into the
middle of the box
and hook up
a weight that you would like to lift
suppose that this is the work you want
to do you want to lift a weight and in
the book since the book is
involves victorian settings the
weight to be lifted in the book is a
little teapot as you mentioned
you can hook up the weights
and suppose that this particle can
exchange heat through the walls of the
box with an environment that's at a
fixed temperature
then you can
unfix the partition so that it can slide
across the box
and the
particle which is a gas will expand
against the partition and push the
partition to the opposite side of the
box and if the teapot is tied to the
partition in the right way then the
teapot will be lifted as the gas is
expanding so the gas expanding performs
useful work in lifting the teapot
by the end of the process we've lifted
the teapot we've done good work but now
we have no idea where in the box the
particle is so we've lost our bit of
information or in other words we have
traded information for work so
information
can serve as a resource and a
thermodynamic task and landauer showed
that also the opposite is true
um that you can invest thermodynamic
work in order
and when we hear things about you know
information destroyed and i was joking
about sabine's you know consistent
harping on this this issue um what does
it mean to destroy information again um
from a simple sense i would never do
this but you know if i take this book we
go to burning man and we throw it into
the bonfire when they're burning the man
uh you know how
it's it's clearly impossible to
reconstruct it i understand that
there'll be heat liberated from the
chemical bonds in here but if you had
the exact same uh book same number of
pages same number of characters but they
were all the letter a
you know or you know every letter was
just permuted and so there's zero uh
there's zero actual info it's total
gibberish the same exact letter so you
can't say there's more ink or less ink
how can you possibly say that the
information
is not destroyed from doing such a thing
even classically
yeah
if you or i
looked at the smoke that came from
one book burning that was
actually my book and the smoke that came
from the book full of gibberish burning
then we couldn't tell the difference
there is still a difference there and in
principle if you had great enough
control over smoke and the heat and all
the air around and
the people around who might have heard
the effects of the crumbling paper
then
with an enormous amount of effort you
could reconstruct the information that
was on the pages but i agree that that
is extremely impractical
so
to those of us who are very limited in
or
practically limited in the way in which
we can
reconstruct
ashes and sound and so on and so forth
into
what used to be present
for all intensive or for all practical
purposes
the information is unrecoverable but it
is still out there in the world just the
information has dispersed into many
different degrees of freedom like and
then in quantum
information paradox or at least in the
black hole information paradox can you
walk us through why you know this is
so monumental that it needs to keep
being solved can you talk about the
black hole information loss paradox and
how it relates to this uh to the you
know to this problem of information
destruction and conservation
suppose that we have
two characters often in information
theory settings they're called alice and
bob but those names are so used so very
very like audrey and baxter yeah yes
victorian alternatives so suppose that
audrey writes down a secret in a diary
and she doesn't want for her obnoxious
little brother baxter to know it so she
throws the diary into a black hole and
says uh nothing will come out of the
black hole as no information can nothing
can escape from a black hole as we all
know not even light can escape that's
why black holes are called black holes
and so my secret is safe
but as hawking told us
black holes radiate
so
baxter can
stay outside the black hole and collect
the radiation that comes out
the radiation will look to him
like it's at thermal equilibrium like
it's
it just has some temperature and
no other
interesting properties that he can see
if he just performs some
simple measurements of local observables
the way that we
for humans who don't have
extremely great control of our
environments
do
so there's a little bit of debate about
what happens when
black hole gets all the way down and
shrinks an enormous amount but
one idea is that it might radiate all of
its mass away as hawking radiation and
so baxter can collect all of the hawking
radiation that has ever formed black
hole
but again if he performs any measurement
that he's practically capable of
performing on this hawking radiation all
he's going to see is some particles at
some temperature and that have no other
interesting or notable features
so the question is where has atlas's
secret gone where has that information
gone
and
so the idea is that the information is
still in the hawking radiation it's just
spread out across the hawking radiation
quantum systems can
share information in entanglement which
is a very strong relationship that
quantum particles can share so if some
information is spread out in
entanglement then it's not just in one
particle it's not just in another
particle and it's not in the sum of
different particles probed independently
it's sort of between the particles and
so in order to so in principle we think
baxter can reconstruct audrey's secret
but in order to do that he would have to
take all these
quanta all these pieces of hawking
radiation and do some massively
complicated
operation on the entire thing
which
would be very very very difficult so for
practical purposes
audrey's information is lost to him
although
it is still present in the correlations
amongst the hawking particles another
fascinating thing you mentioned in the
book is this uh
this concept of a boltzmann brain let's
stick into outer space stay with the uh
outer space theme
and uh let's examine what is a boltzmann
brain
and what is a boltzmann balance and how
do these concepts relate boltzmann
obviously is looms large over all of
our discussions of thermodynamics and
we'll get into the modern incarnations
of boltzmann um
but but what is a boltzmann brain and um
and how does it relate to this concept
you talk about a boltzmann
balance so boltzmann brains are
rather more cosmological than i can
claim too much expertise about the idea
is that it's pretty improbable that we
should exist as our this advanced
civilization with um
quite a lot of
conscious beings and
order as opposed to the
highly entropic systems that we might
instead expect to find across the
universe so you can imagine
you can imagine that this entire
civilization
has just
come into being fluctuated into being
for a fraction of a second
and
your memories were just created in this
fraction of a second you haven't
actually
lived your life up until this point
you've just fluctuated into being and
soon you'll fluctuate out of being
and people have estimated the
probability that
we are in fact a boltzmann brain or the
experience of a boltzmann brain
and argued about the relative
probabilities are being boltzmann brains
or of our existing in this relatively
low entropy state which kind of seems
improbable
the book features what i call boltzmann
balance i came up with that term because
the term that's used among scientists is
free energy difference and i think that
has too many syllables especially for a
book
so i just renamed it
a boltzmann balance or free energy
difference shows up in the concept of
fluctuation relations these are
equalities equations
that
kind of enhance the second law of
thermodynamics so the second law of
thermodynamics can be stated as an
inequality as we said before if you have
any closed isolated system its entropy
will increase or remain constant
and so it obeys an inequality
an equality is stronger it tells us
some exact information
but the inequality doesn't tell us how
much the entropy is going to grow so
it'd be nice to replace the second law
with an equality and also the second law
strictly speaking only holds for very
very very very very large systems it
would be nice to have extensions that
hold for small systems that such as even
single molecules
so there's a family of equations that
have been derived over the past few
decades but one of my colleagues at the
university of maryland chris jarzinski
has one that's named after him although
he's so humble
everyone else calls it charzinski's
equality but he calls it the
non-equilibrium fluctuation relation
which
has even more syllables than
free energy difference
but these
are
valuable equations they've been that
they've been derived theoretically and
also tested experimentally for instance
with single strands of dna
and
strands of rna and very tiny pendulums
they've started out as equations that
govern classical systems they've also
been extended to the quantum regime
and one reason why they're valuable is
they
relate properties of equilibrium systems
to properties of far from equilibrium
systems so a system is at equilibrium
if it's kind of in a boring state it's
large-scale properties like its energy
and its volume remain constant and
there's no flow of anything such as
energy or particles into or out of the
system no net flow of anything
so equilibrium is
kind of boring um
but it's it's thought about a lot in
thermodynamics a lot of the conventional
theory of thermodynamics from the 1800s
deals with equilibrium because since it
is boring it's relatively easy to
describe
but
so much of our world is out of
equilibrium for instance you and i are
out of equilibrium as living beings if
we were at equilibrium we would be dead
yes
but
equilibrium properties well they're
useful to know about for the purposes of
chemistry and biochemistry and
pharmacology so people want to
understand
certain equilibrium properties of
systems and one of these is what i call
the boltzmann balance but we can't it's
really difficult to measure a boltzmann
balance and
effectively we can't really measure it
directly because
no system is
really out of equilibrium during any
process that we perform on it for
instance if we have a gas in a box and
we perform some process like compressing
it we compress at some finite speed so
we're going to roil up the gas a little
bit so it's going to come out of
equilibrium so how do we measure these
equilibrium properties well
my colleague chris and
others
showed that
one of some of these equalities
fluctuation relations can interrelate
properties of equilibrium systems which
we want to know for chemistry and
pharmacology and so on like the
boltzmann balance those properties can
be related to properties of out of
equilibrium systems which we can access
so we can run some experiments on out of
equilibrium systems like by compressing
a gas
at a quick speed we can perform a whole
bunch of trials
plug our data into one of these
equations and infer
those equilibrium properties that are so
useful
thank you that's really lovely and
thorough description of this very
complicated phenomena another phenomenon
that i'm
you know kind of alternately confused as
to whether it's hype
or our best hope is quantum computing
you talk about
these notions in quantum computing i'll
say something that i heard someone say
in response to richard feynman you know
once who said something about uh quantum
computers as we know had a lot to say
about them uh but really they said
something like to the effect well
quantum computers are great uh for
simulating quantum computers and you
know describing how quantum computers
work but you know besides that and maybe
cryptographic you know uh you know
breaking of cryptography uh which again
you hear about all the time like
quantum computers can break uh you know
all all sorts of codes and then uh
encryption
and then uh and then you also hear they
can't and so first of all what is a
quantum computer what's the simplest
kind of explanation for that and then
are they good for you know are we going
to have a quantum iphone anytime soon
[Music]
the quantum computers are technological
technologies that
exist in
relatively primitive forms we're
building more advanced versions a
quantum computer
consists of
particles that obey the laws of quantum
physics to the exclusion of classical
physics so my laptop which i am using to
connect to to record this podcast is a
classical system so it
obeys
newton's equations of motion
and it obeys the physics of our everyday
world
quantum systems as i mentioned can share
entanglements which is a very
strong relationship or correlation
between particles
and
very loosely speaking
sort of cartoon picture of what
entanglement can accomplish is if you
have two particles that are entangled
and you take them far apart even to
opposite sides of the world you measure
one of the particles then the other
particle will change instantaneously
so there's
so entanglement is an unusual feature of
quantum physics
and
it can be used to process information in
ways impossible for just classical
computers even classical super computers
so that's what quantum computers are
we
have there are two different classes of
quantum computers one consists of
simulators these are
quantum computers that do simulate other
quantum systems
and these have existed for a number of
years i've been working with
experimentalists to use
quantum simulators and they've been very
useful in
discovering or
observing
phase transition between exotic phases
of matter analogous to liquid and solid
but the phases that are observed with
these quantum computers are ones that
are unavailable in our everyday world
and also observing features of systems
that
are let's say counter-intuitive
according to
those of us who study thermodynamics
then there are
in addition to quantum simulators
universal quantum computers so these are
being built currently we have
quantum computers
that have
50 to 100 qubits or basic units of
quantum information
we're going to need quantum computers
with hundreds of thousands of qubits in
order to
realize algorithms like
the
breaking of rsa encryption which you
just mentioned
so a lot of work needs to be done to get
to that stage but
i think that most of us in the quantum
physics community believes that we will
realize these quantum computers
what are some applications of quantum
computers you mentioned the possibility
of
breaking cryptographic schemes
fortunately and these cryptographic
schemes are common so we have
used them when accessing and using the
internet
fortunately quantum physics doesn't only
break cryptography it also offers
resources for securing information in
ways that classical systems can't
by
because of the quantum uncertainty
principle that's often associated with
heisenberg
also
i agree it might sound a little bit dull
to say oh quantum computers will be very
useful in
chemistry and materials research and
development
but the implications have the potential
to
be very significant
for instance
in some countries in the world
food security is at crisis levels in
some countries in the world food
security is at the highest level ever
achieved in human civilization so
fertilizer is extremely important to the
world and about three percent of the
total energy output of the globe is
invested in creating fertilizer that's a
lot of energy
why do we invest so much energy in
creating fertilizer
because we use a process that was
developed in 1909
long time ago
it turns out that
bacteria can perform this process a lot
more efficiently
but they use a molecule nitrogenase
that's so complicated we can't unlock
its secrets on classical computers but
nitrogenase is a quantum particle so it
is natural to
unlock its secrets with a quantum
computer so folks at microsoft put out
an algorithm for
a possible application of quantum
computers to fertilizer and different
companies around the world
are
trying to find
optimization problems and other
chemistry and materials problems for
which quantum computers might be very
natural and helpful
so i think another way people get
fertilizer is using compost
you know which is uh decaying worm
poop and uh and things like that and so
now i want to go from that to bitcoin uh
because
uh i you know i hear a lot about um
about uh you know how energy inefficient
you know blockchain and bitcoin in
particular is and how it uses up you
know tremendous amount uh of of the
world's energy resources and yet when we
look at you know information and you
know converting to heat you know if you
just look at an individual um an
individual bit erasure or something like
that
uh
it seems to me that both you know
quantum computers could
alleviate that of course you need a
dilution refrigerator and you know you
need to supply that with power but you
know my university covers that uh as
long as i keep paying my taxes and you
my beloved audience keeps paying your
taxes um but you know could you imagine
two things happening one that the
environment you know the energy cost
would come down because of quantum you
know effects and quantum computing
and that the cost to erase a bit and you
know cause it to be zeroed out so to
speak would be so minimal that the
energy would go down dramatically um in
addition to the you know breaking of the
encryption you know kind of algorithms
that are used to secure the blockchain
are there kinds of implications for
uh you know quantum computing that could
you know radically alter our you know
investments and and things like that
that are stored in as purely
mathematical problems and uh i'm
speaking particularly about about
blockchain here but if you have other
examples that would be great to know too
so
what are the implications for you know
lowering the energy cost and and erase
your cost in the information processing
strictly on future financial instruments
like bitcoin
classical computers now since they're
more or less the only computers that we
have widely available
are being used to
solve problems
that
for instance and materials research and
development could be quantum and could
involve a lot of entanglement and in
order to simulate a quantum system of
some size
the
size of the classical system that we
need to perform that computation is
exponentially large
in the original system size and so this
exponentially large classical computer
is going to consume
a lot of energy whereas to simulate a
quantum system
uh of some size we need a quantum system
a quantum computer that's of a somewhat
comparable size so that does offer some
opportunity for trying to reduce the
energy cost
a quantum thermodynamics colleague of
mine alexia fev recently wrote a paper
that's related as you pointed out
we need to cool down systems so that
they exhibit quantum behaviors so
quantum computers do require
very intense refrigerators which
themselves require work or an energy
investment
and
according to alexia's writing the
view that the community has taken is
we're just going to achieve quantum
computing at any cost
but an energy cost is a considerable
cost to the environment and to the
economy so maybe we should change our
metrics in order to
incorporate into them not only the
accuracy of our answers but also the
energy cost of achieving those answers
and
you know if you were to uh kind of
advise a young person you know getting
into interested you know typically if
this is kind of interdisciplinary as you
mentioned before this new field you know
quantum thermodynamicist which i had to
work on with a speaking coach for a long
time to get that right um but you know
how would you by say a young person
comes to you wants to research with you
um what do you say to to her to him uh
as where this field is going to go uh
there's a lot of hype there's a lot of
promise there's a lot of successes
it's an early s day in some sense uh but
how would you advise a young person in
in terms of this field would you advise
it as a career choice and if so what are
some of the not the job prospects and
you know what kind of starting salary
are you making but in terms of
intellectual capital what do you see is
the as the you know give me your
elevator pitch for a young person to go
into this field quantum thermodynamics
is in an extremely exciting phase now
it
had its roots in the 1930s and there was
a little more development over the
ensuing decades
but it's really experienced a burst of
activity over the past decade and that
burst
is
mainly outside of the united states
finally americans are getting interested
because
of
experiments that have been happening
thermodynamics has traditionally been
very
theoretical even borderline
philosophical but over the past decade
we've had increasingly amazing control
over quantum systems in part because
people have been
developing techniques to control quantum
systems because they're trying to build
quantum technologies like quantum
computers and we can use those control
techniques and use them to
realize quantum thermodynamics
experiments test the theory
build quantum engines for the first time
so experiments are growing i think
they're going to continue to grow quite
a lot over the next few years i've been
working with quite a few labs that are
eager to get into quantum thermodynamics
and so we've been collaborating on
taking theory that i've worked on and
bringing it into reality that's gonna
happen a lot more
also
an opportunity that i think the quantum
thermodynamics community is right now
just beginning to pivot to really dig
into
is
practicality conventional thermodynamics
developed hand-in-hand with the
industrial revolution which was
eminently practical
and quantum thermodynamics has again
been theoretical it's been foundational
it's provided a lot of great insights
and helped us understand better even
what the difference is between the
quantum world and the classical world
we have designed technologies like
quantum batteries and engines and
refrigerators and some of these
some of these technologies can even
excel
do better than their classical
counterparts according to certain
metrics we started realizing these in
laboratories but at the moment these
experiments are very proof of principle
they're not useful in a practical sense
in order to
run a quantum engine to get it to
perform work for you you have to cool it
down and so
spend energy on refrigeration you have
to spend a lot of energy on on
controlling the system and you get very
little energy out
but there are opportunities to make
quantum thermodynamics practical for
instance i'm working with a lab at shaw
mars university in sweden on
creating a quantum refrigerator that
services quantum computers and according
to
numerical
predictions which have yet to be burned
out in the lab since experiments are
just starting basically this week
but hopefully they will be realized
according to these predictions the this
quantum refrigerator according to some
metrics can perform as well as or maybe
even a little bit better than some of
its classical counterparts so i think
that a great opportunity
right now for quantum thermodynamics is
to
yield useful quantum thermodynamic
technologies
technologies
and it's interesting as you point out in
the book
frequently resonating is kind of this
notion of serendipity and and how
sometimes we we don't really
get what we started off looking for and
you know you end up getting uh you know
something in cosmology when you're
thinking about thermodynamics or you end
up getting something in uh in
thermometry when you think about uh
refrigeration actually that literally
happened to me long before you and i met
my uh one of my
graduate students stephanie moyerman who
is now um who now works at ebay and
probably makes twice what i make as a
public servant but anyway she uh she and
i were trying to think of a way to cool
our volumetric detectors down as much as
possible using pure solid state rather
than liquid helium and which is kind of
finicky and and frustrating to work with
and so we use the super conducting uh
insulating superconducting normal uh
tunnel junctions called sinus for
superconducting insulating normal
insulating superconducting that she
really invented
and uh we were going to use those to
cool not like this massive block of
focal plane we realized oh you only need
to cool this tiny little detector you
know of of of superconductor down uh to
you know close to absolute zero but why
cool down this huge cryostat to do that
just cool the sensor itself so we went
through it and we found uh you know you
could do it but it added a lot of
complexity and we actually got some
cooling power but on the other hand it
turned out that these little
refrigerators were actually
self-calibrating quantum thermometers
which was kind of unusual and and
throughout the book you talk a lot about
thermometry and i wonder if you could if
you could talk just in the last few
minutes that we have together just sing
the praises of the humble thermometer
and uh and why it figures so
so uh prominently in your wonderful book
quantum steampunk
existence of a thermometer is basically
one of
the foundational laws of thermodynamics
often called the zeroth law of
thermodynamics because
people already developed the first law
on the second law and so on by the time
that the zeroth law was developed but
the developers thought this is such an
important law it should really come
first so it's called the zeroth law and
in honor of that the book has a chapter
zero for the prologue
the zeroth law of thermodynamics says
that suppose that i have
some system again in the book where in a
victorian setting so suppose that i have
a pudding that's at
equilibrium at thermal equilibrium
with you know a system that you have a
that's a blessing
a trifle
and the trifle is at thermal equilibrium
with
a cake of some sort um
by
so then my system is also at thermal
equilibrium with cake and so thermal
equilibrium is transitive what do we
mean by thermal equilibrium two systems
are at thermal equilibrium if they have
the same temperature and basically as
much heat flows into one system as flows
out
so there's a balance
so according to the zeroth law of
thermodynamics
thermal equilibrium and having the same
temperature is a transitive property and
that central system so your trifle
serves as a thermometer
that diagnoses the temperature of my
system if your thermometer is used and
together with knowledge of the system of
the temperature of the third system so
temperature is a very
fundamental quantity
in thermodynamics it tells us about the
ratio between or how energy changes if
entropy changes and vice versa
and it can be
tricky to figure out how to
measure the temperature of a quantum
system because what do we do in order to
measure a temperature well we take some
probe system our thermometer and we put
it in contact with the system whose
temperature we want to measure we let
the two systems sit there for a while so
that the thermometer can come to thermal
equilibrium with to be at the same
temperature as the system of interest
and we take away the thermometer and we
read the thermometer
but if the system of interest is a
quantum system
then
it's very delicate
quantum systems can very easily
interact with any stray particles that
are around and lose their quantum
behaviors we say that these quantum
systems decohere they lose their quantum
natures and they cease to be useful as
controlled quantum systems so if you
want to take a thermometer and put it in
contact with a quantum system and wait
for a while
then by the time you read your
thermometer the quantum system of
interest might no longer be of interest
so people have been developing all
different techniques to
use
other quantum phenomena in order to
measure temperature in different ways
very good well i've uh really loved this
book and i love talking to you and i
hope we get to meet one day and i just
want to reiterate how enjoyable this
book is for young and for old the
children of all ages step right up hear
ye hear ye and we've been talking to you
with nicole younger halpern
he's a theoretical physicist now at the
university of maryland uh what is this
joint quantum institute what is that um
what was the raison d'etre for that the
university of maryland has a partnership
with the national institute of standards
and technology which is right nearby
back a number of years ago
before everyone every institution was
trying to say oh we have a quantum
institute and we're developing a quantum
team before
quantum technologies and quantum
information science were big deals that
everyone's investing in as they are
today
quantum information didn't exist as a
field it was very hard to get jobs and
no one would hire a quantum information
scientist as a quantum information
scientist such positions didn't exist
but there were very few institutions
that realized the promise of quantum
information science and started
investing in it early the university of
maryland and the national institute of
standards and technology nist formed a
partnership to invest in quantum science
including quantum information science so
they created a joint institute called
the joint quantum institute the jqi
and
that was successful
then
another center was formed to
be shared between
nist and the university of maryland and
that's called quix the joint center for
quantum information and computer science
it's more mathematical and computer
sciencey whereas the jqi has more
experimentalists
so that's actually what partially what
drew me to maryland it has this
very
rich long history of investing in
quantum science so it has this massive
quantum community with people from all
different perspectives from computer
science and experiments and physics and
engineering it's been a lot of fun to
participate in
that's wonderful well
nicole we've reached a time that is
customary for my guest to go
into the impossible if you are willing i
would love to ask you my patented
thrilling three final questions are you
willing to go into the impossible
okay we start the thrilling three
with a
question about your near-term future and
that has to do with something uh known
as an ethical will and that's a
statement of wisdom or values that you
most want to articulate to future
generations when you leave this mortal
coil at the age of 120 or beyond
and actually you touch upon time
reversal or time
time stabilization in the context of
biological entities i'll leave that
lovely lively description for those of
the audience to read and devour but i
want to ask you at 120 what ethical
wisdom would you like to bequeath in
your ethical will
[Music]
i'll
interpret that question
as meaning in my case what
what would you like to leave as your
scientific ethical will because i feel
like i can tackle that a little bit
better than an ethical will that
encompasses all of ethics which i don't
feel like enough of an expert on
so i'm
talked with i've talked with
a number of former students of eddie
farhy who
is
a professor at physics at mit and now an
employee at google because again
everyone's getting involved in quantum
computing including behemoths like
google
so
according to one student eddie
said once
when talking about writing science paper
papers for the scientific literature
we make works of lasting value and i
think that that's a great motto to have
nowadays there is this
atmosphere of publish or perish so
people sometimes crank out papers just
as quickly as they can
even if the papers are not
great advances
but i think that
a
goal to shoot for is to create works of
lasting value that we will be proud of
for a long time and we'll have impact
for a long time lovely
the next question involves also the
future but uh maybe the future more of
your field and that involves this
concept of
arthur c clarke evoked in 2001 a space
odyssey this concept of these monoliths
these giant
you know maybe quantum computers
actually but anyway there are these
giant monoliths huge sculpt we don't
know what they are they could be time
capsules or whatever i'm gonna ask you
if you had to right now
uh engrave a monolith or you know an
encode within a monolith or
put an sd card into monolith with kind
of a summary of of what your field has
accomplished and the thing that you
collectively are most proud of your
field rather collectively what have you
what have you noticed what would you put
on a monolith to brag and kind of beat
your chest about and have a little
swagger about in your field for some
alien species to eventually find and be
unable to you know eject the usb drive
in their spaceship
i think it's remarkable that the laws of
thermodynamics still stand
and again they govern so very many other
theories
furthermore we can write the laws of
thermodynamics not only in the classical
language in which they were first
developed but also in quantum language
so that it's clear how they govern
classical and quantum systems as well as
information processing so i think that
the
laws of thermodynamics as they apply to
classical and quantum systems would be
worth recording yeah yeah you mentioned
the famous quote i forget who said it
but you know if you if you violate you
know some some cosmological you know
principle or or you know even some
conservation of of momentum as paulie
did at some point or tried to do
um you know you can you can at least
maybe not get get too much trouble for
that but if you try to violate the laws
of thermodynamics there is no hope for
you
so they're amazingly resilient if
nothing else so that would be a great
one
okay now we're gonna go backwards in
time and now we're gonna get personal uh
although i know not everyone's
comfortable with getting personal but i
do want to ask you a personal question
and it relates to the origin of this
podcast
and it's related to sir arthur c clark's
third law which states the only way of
discovering the limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible that's the origin
and the name of the podcast
so let me ask you nicole what aspect of
life or your work perplexed you
mystified you you know 10 15 years ago
when you were younger and
but yet you overcame and had the courage
to do as you've done and go into the
impossible including writing this
magnificent book which is a tremendous
accomplishment
[Music]
something that i didn't expect to be
so possible
was to have a liberal arts education so
enrich my physics research
when i entered physics grad school i was
with students who had studied primarily
physics and math for the past four years
whereas i had studied physics and math
but i had spent some of my time studying
german literature and art history
and i felt
different and behind
but i've found over the years that
having a liberal arts education is
so useful for my physics research it
helped teach me to bring together
diverse ideas from very different
disciplines
and put them together so to bridge
fields and also
gather information in ways that isn't
always obvious if we have just a
scientific training
so something that was surprisingly
possible to me was
to have a
rich physics career that's been enhanced
by a liberal arts education
and that's wonderful well nicole i want
to thank you for coming on into the
impossible podcast for this book which
has received delightful praise from
folks like anna weltman author of
supermath who called it introducing
curious stem incline novices to the
concept of quantum steampunk
younger halpern fluidly weaves together
playful tone with a steampunk narrative
and her own personal experiences it's as
much a memoir as it is an explication of
some of the most fascinating mystifying
and and uh and delightful concepts in
all of science and i want to thank you
for coming on the show today nicole
thanks so much for having me here it's
been a pleasure
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from that
[Music]
well i hope you loved this fascinating
journey into the impossible with dr
nicole younger halpern as much as i did
we covered so much ground and quantum
computing thermodynamics maxwell's demon
and much more i know if you love this
interview you'll definitely want to
check out this special playlist that i
created just for you contains my curated
greatest hits on thermodynamics the
arrow of time and even quantum computing
with one of nicole's advisors john
preskill the final professor of physics
at caltech and a great friend
so
join me click here for the special
playlist and don't forget to subscribe
[Music]